We are here today,
around them the association of bündniserer Wagenknecht,
To present reason and justice
and sits in front of them
the board of this association.
I am the chairwoman,
Christian leihe is vice chairman,
Lukas beautiful is our managing director
ralsulikat is our treasurer
and Sarah warnknecht
is, of course,
also a member of the Executive Board.
This association has the goal,
to launch a new party
and they all took that from the press correctly,
that the decision for it has now been made.
This morning saravan are servants,
Christian lend Luca beautifully and I
together with 7 other deputies
of the Left Group
From the party
the left kicked out.
This decision was not easy for us,
after all,
the left one was many years for us,
even decades
the political homeland.
Nevertheless,
we are convinced of this,
that the 1 was a necessary and correct step.
For a long time we have fought about it,
that the course of the party leadership,
has led to insignificance in federal politics,
that this course is corrected.
For a long time we have hoped,
that it is for all of us
a place in the left
and also a common future
can give.
Also in summer,
as I have explained,
For political reasons
not again for the chairmanship of the parliamentary group
to want to run for office,
I had not yet completely given up on this hope.
Since the last European election,
the left-wing
experienced a large number of election defeats.
On the part of the party executive
never a critical discussion
with the reasons
given for this repeated failure.
With the election in Hesse
is the left From the last parliament of a.
West german flown nationwide
and not even through it
1 Rethinking of the party leadership has begun,
but instead
more
the responsibility of Sarah Wagenknecht was attributed.
That's what showed us,
that the time has come,
to leave the left.
Ultimately,
one must say,
with this departure we also comply with the wish,
the
often by party executive andfunktionierstkreisen
was expressed,
that Sarah and all,
who are committed to their political goals
and conviction identify,
should leave the left.
It is important for us to emphasize,
that we go without resentment
and we also take many despite all the difficulties
good memories of our time in the left with.
We are ready to do this,
until the actual formation of the new party
in the left group
To stay
and also have today
made the appropriate request to do so.
We wish for an orderly transition
also in the interest and in responsibility
for the employees of the Group.
We see that many people in our country
have lost confidence in politics.
You do not feel through any of the existing parties
more represented.
We want to fill the existing gap
close in the German party system
and a party reasons,
that for economic reason,
social justice - peace and freedom.
Because we don't want to stand idly by,
that there are more and more people,
which are involved in the polarization of politics
between the in and traffic light government
and the AfD,
which is partly right-wing extremist
be driven.
We don't want to stand idly by,
that more and more people are disappointed
turn away from democracy
and no longer go to elections at all.
We don't want to stand idly by.
That the majority of the population
factually no political representation in our country
has.
We found a new party
Out of responsibility for our society,
for the people in our country,
for all who are not on the sunny side of life,
for all who work hard,
but from the prevailing politics
be abandoned
and for a stable economy.
We are convinced of this,
that we will be successful
and we all bring a lot of experience,
that help us to do so,
be it For political reasons,
through longstanding commitment
and organizational leadership responsibility
or through sound professional experience
in the private sector.
I myself,
for example,
was not always a deputy.
I am a lawyer.
I was before my time
in the Bundestag
10 years as synthekosan lawyer and contract manager
in a globally active company
of the automotive industry.
Today we present to them our political cornerstones
before and for that I hand over to Sarah Wachenknecht.